[Musique]
la bonsoir à tous mardi 19 mars
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
c'est le tour d'horizon de l'actualité
locale et régionale tout de suite les
titres de cette édition c'est la journée
mondiale du travail social les syndicats
a appelé ce mardi à une grève
interprofessionnelle dans les yvelines
les agents du secteur social de conseil
départemental manifestaient contre le
manque d'effectifs mobilisation
également des enseignants dans plusieurs
établissements scolaires du territoire
mieux s'intégrer grâce à la langue de
molière l'objectif de l'école française
des femmes le dispositif qui vient de
fêter ses dix ans d'existence est
présent à mantes-la-jolie depuis janvier
au sein de cette école yvelinoise une
vingtaine de femmes suivent des cours de
perfectionnement du français et puis
c'est un événement au profit de l'unicef
la nuit de l'eau se tient ce samedi
partout en france notamment à la piscine
des mureaux les fonds récoltés cette
année serviront à remettre en état le
réseau d'eau potable en haïti détruit
par un ouragan invités de ce journal
philippe journée quand de l'unicef 78 et
nous parlerons à tout à l'heure
aussi de la création de la première
coopérative citoyenne d'énergies
renouvelables sa fondation officielle
est prévue ce vendredi à la verrière
près de 3 300 personnes se sont réunies
hier sur la place de la république à
poissy un rassemblement à l'initiative
de la municipalité en soutien aux
victimes de l'attentât de christchurch
en nouvelle zélande
vendredi un homme a tiré à l'armé à feu
dans deux mosquées de la ville faisant
50 morts et une vingtaine de blessés
hier pour la cérémonie aux côtés du
maire karl olive les présidents de
plusieurs associations musulmanes
les habitants ont ensuite déposer fleurs
et bougies au pied des pancartes
installées devant la mairie les agents
du secteur de l'action sociale du
département des yvelines se sont
mobilisés ce matin à versailles une
manifestation dans le cadre de la
journée mondiale du travail social
plusieurs revendications notamment le
manque de moyens et d'effectifs dans le
cadre des missions d'accompagnement et
de protection de l'enfance les détails
de nicolas landry
ils étaient une centaine d'agents du
conseil départemental des yvelines des
travailleurs sociaux manifestantes
devant l'hôtel du département ce mardi
19 mars à l'appel de la cgt de la
fédération autonome de la fonction
publique territoriale
leurs principales revendications la
baisse des moyens budgétaires alloués au
secteur de l'action sociale des yvelines
le constat c'est qu'en fait on nous
alourdit la charge de travail en créant
de nouvelles missions des nouvelles
missions avec lesquels on pourrait être
d'accord on réorganise l'accueil on
réorganise l'enfance la santé
l'insertion et le travail social
mais à chaque fois c'est sans moyens et
avec des missions complémentaires
moi on peut pas mener la même qualité de
service et quand on est aux prises avec
des perses des familles qui sont
surendettés en procédure d'expulsion de
la violence conjugale
on a une charge mentale lourd à absorber
pour mener à bien son travail et on se
dit bon bah maintenant j'ai plus que 20
minutes pour gérer ce que je faisais en
1h30 quoi assistant social éducateurs
spécialisés ou encore conseillers en
économie sociale et familiale les postes
occupés par ces agents dans les centres
de protection maternelle et infantile ou
de planification d'éducation familiale
leur mission accompagner les publics en
difficulté
nous demandons aux départements
davantage de moyens de changer sa
politique de réduction des effectifs de
réductions budgétaires
en considérant que la priorité d'une
collectivité départementale doit être de
consacrer son effort et notamment son
effort financier à destination des
familles les plus en difficulté
sollicité le conseil départemental n'a
pas donné suite à notre demande
d'interview
et en cette journée de grève
interprofessionnelle mobilisation
également des enseignants dans le
primaire environ 100 écoles sur les 998
des yvelines ont été concernés ce mardi
d'après le syndicat snuipp fsu est des
revendications pour le pouvoir d'achat
et la justice fiscale dans le secondaire
plusieurs établissements ont été
également touchés par la grève au
collège de la géo à elancourt 80 % des
professeurs titulaires ont profité de la
journée pour dénoncer une nouvelle fois
à la baisse de la dotation horaire un
nombre d'heures allouées pour l'an
prochain au collège en diminution qui va
conduire selon les grévistes à des
classes surchargées une détérioration
des conditions d'apprentissage et un
accompagnement personnalisé sacrifiés
est d'après les chiffres perceuse les
chiffres fournis par don par ses
enseignants les classes de 6e compte
déjà trente élèves cette année est les
propos sont recueillis par manon varaldo
on nous demande c'est son mono textes
actuellement de faire de la
différenciation pédagogique d'adapter
vraiment aux difficultés de chaque élève
mais dans notre collège on a justement
des élèves qui ont tous des
problématiques très différentes et ça
devient difficile compte tenu des moyens
alloués 2
de pouvoir faire cette différenciation
nous ne sommes pas des gestionnaires
avec des comptes financiers à régler ou
des des élèves a calculé dans nombre de
classes à avoir donc pour nous
aujourd'hui cette mobilisation était
importante
cet événement se déroule ce samedi à la
piscine des mureaux la nuit de l'eau se
tient de 19h à 23h proposée par le
cercle aquasports des mureaux un
événement au profit de l'unicef l'
agence de l'onu pour l'amélioration et
la promotion de la condition à des
enfants pour en parler philippe jean
descamps bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
représentant de l'unicef 78 alors les
fonds récoltés pour cet événement vont
servir cette année à la remise en état
du réseau d'eau potable en haïti avant
d'en parler présentez-nous déjà cette
nuit de l'eau c'est un événement
national quel est son principe
alors c'est la douzième année que la
nuit de l'eau a lieu c'est à
l'initiative de la fédération française
de natation et donc des clubs de
natation dès qu'ils sont en france cette
année il ya 230 piscine de 130 clubs qui
vont participer à cette nuit de l'eau
l'année dernière cela avait cet
événement avait rapporté deux cent
cinquante mille euros ce qui est assez
considérable mais on espère que cette
année l'unicef france espère que cette
année mais on ira encore plus loin et on
mettra un point final à pouvoir vaincre
le choléra en haïti
et il ya un art un par un par mois et
une marraine pour l'occasion ça fait
plusieurs années alors c'est ma
cinquième année c'est la cinquième année
que camille lacourt le quintuple
champion du monde et champion d'europe
de natation et que le riz thilleman miss
france journaliste sportive aujourd'hui
parraine cet événement parraine et
marraines cet événement ils sont
vraiment en plein dedans tu as mis la
cour par exemple était en haïti l'année
dernière en 1920 en 2018 où il a pu
constater de lui-même par sa de ses yeux
le travail effectué par l'unicef et
c'est pour ça que cette année encore là
il revient il
il redonne son image tout son savoir
tout son coeur aussi au profit de cette
nuit de l'eau et donc pour sensibiliser
à cette thématique de l'accès à l'eau
potable est aussi alex à
l'assainissement plus d'un milliard de
personnes aujourd'hui dans le monde
n'ont pas accès à l'eau potable
les enfants sont les premières victimes
de
de ce manque alors les enfants sont bien
sûrs les premières victimes de ce manque
parce qu'une eau polluée
ça engendre des maladies haïti le
choléra mais c'est une maladie liée à
l'eau insalubre qui est consommé
malheureusement par des enfants par
toute la population mais et notamment
pour les enfants qui sont beaucoup plus
sensibles à cette bactérie
c'est très simple à vaincre finalement
le choléra c'est une maladie mortelle
mais simple à 20 h elle provoque des
diarrhées très aiguë mais quelquefois on
on a pas le temps de voir qu'on est
atteint par le choléra dont il faut des
sels de réhydratation immédiatement et
puis il faut bien sûr pour éviter de
consommer de l'eau insalubre ima il faut
des moyens d'assainissement et c'est ce
à quoi depuis trois ans l'unicef
s'applique à faire en haïti l'unicef est
en charge au sein de l'onu de tout ce
qui concerne l'eau et l'adduction d'eau
potable parce que l'eau est essentielle
à la vie on peut vivre sans manger
pendant une semaine deux semaines voire
trois semaines sans eau on ne peut pas
vivre plus de trois jours donc c'est
dire l'importance capitale de l'eau et
d'une eau salubre alors l'article 24 de
la convention internationale des droits
de l'enfant est clair sur le sujet
chaque enfant a le droit d'être protégé
et soigner des maladies de boire et de
manger suffisamment pour grandir en
bonne santé l'eau finalement c'est un
droit fondamental même si aujourd'hui on
a l'impression que c'est plutôt un luxe
l'eau l'eau est un droit fondamental je
vous dis pourquoi c'est un droit
fondamental c'est que sans eux on ne
peut pas vivre
le corps humain est constitué de 75 %
d'eau 75 ou 80 % d'eau c'est dire donc
une importance capitale pour la vie que
représente l'eau et et l'eau potable
l'eau sale hulot que l'on peut boire
la terre c'est 90% d'eau mais
malheureusement c'est de l'eau salée
c'est de l'eau des océans l'eau potable
c'est une infime partie 2
de lucchi que l'on peut trouver sur
terre il faut savoir que c'est toujours
la même eau depuis l'origine des temps
c'est toujours la même eau potable que
nous buvons selo que buvaient les
dinosaures aujourd'hui que nous buvons
aujourd'hui donc il ne faut pas la
gâcher il ne faut pas la polluer et il
faut surtout pouvoir créer des systèmes
de purification de l'eau des usines de
purification d'eau
c'est essentiel parce que le cycle de
l'eau c'est un cycle continu elle c'est
toujours le même
l'eau s'évapore de la mer l'eau est
puisée dans les rivières on la consomme
et on la rejette
on la rejette polluer très souvent
faibles et l'utilisent pour faire des
toilettes pour faire la nourriture pour
aller aux toilettes et vouloir y est
tout à l'heure des conséquences sur la
santé de l'employé aussi des
conséquences sur l'éducation des enfants
dans certains pays sont corvée d'eau et
ne peuvent pas se rendre à l'école
alors oui malheureusement et c'est
surtout les filles dans dans plusieurs
pays d'afrique je pense notamment au
mali par exemple et bien les filles sont
obligées de faire parfois des dizaines
de kilomètres pour aller puiser un peu
d'eau au puits aller chercher une pruche
d'eau puissent leur demande un temps fou
et ce temps massa ne leur permet pas
d'aller à l'école et pourtant l'école
est essentielle c'est essentiel pour
apprendre bien sûr ali raconté à a et à
écrire mais c'est également essentiel
pour pour connaître la bcd de l'hygiène
l'unicef quand elle crée une école en
afrique on a eu un progrès mais on a
créé de nombreuses écoles au togo par
exemple eh bien ces écoles permettait
aux jeunes d'apprendre avec leurs livres
mais aussi d'apprendre l'hygiène
d'apprendre la santé les écoles c'était
un lieu de rassemblement c'est un lieu
de rassemblement où il ya un dispensaire
où il ya une infirmière où il ya des
toilettes bien séparées entre garçons et
filles des toilettes ne sont pas
reversés à la rue comme ça qu'ils qui
sont épurées et là cette année on le
disait c'est pour financer la remise en
état du
réseau d'eau potable en haïti alors 7
qui a été touché par l'ouragan yamaha il
ya deux ans
alors malheureusement haïti joue de
malheur de malheur au malheur c'est le
pays déjà le plus pauvre des caraïbes
c'est l'un des pays les plus pauvres du
monde qui n'a donc pas les moyens de
faire face à certaines catastrophes
naturelles et là notamment c'était
matthews en 2016 un ouragan terrible qui
a dévasté justement une partie de cette
ré de ce réseau d'adduction d'eau
potable qui avait été mise en place dans
plusieurs régions d'haïti à quatre
régions qui ont été particulièrement
frappées par matthews et alors que
l'unicef avait avait fait un travail de
remise en état d' malheureusement il ya
irma qui allait encore l'année dernière
et hervé lot il faut à nouveau c'était
beaucoup moins loin moins violent - il
ya eu moins de 2 de tragédies bien
évidemment mais il faut à chaque fois
remettre le travail
se remettre au travail et il faut il
faut le faire parce que je vous dis là
grâce au travail que de dos l'unicef et
de l'om s l'agencé mondiale de la santé
oms agences de l'onu et l'ol aussi où on
n'arrive pratiquement à éradiquer la
question du choléra le problème du
choléra mais en 2018 c'est à dire
l'année dernière il y a eu trois 1786
cas recensés de choléra tout
l'importance de récolter les fonds
n'arrivent à l'apprendre cet entretien
philippe journée 41 décès seulement
alors qu'il y avait 122 décès un an
auparavant
c'est donc dire il ne faut pas baisser
les bras il ya encore du travail
il ne faut pas se relâcher le message
est passé et venez donc à cette nuit de
l'eau samedi 23 mars à la piscine des
mureaux ça se déroule de 19h à 23h
toutes les informations l'entrée est à 2
euros l'entrée est à 2 euros c'est
important de le préciser les
informations sur le site du comité des
yvelines de l'unicef merci philippe jean
descamps d'être passé sur ce mercato
représentant de l'unicef 78 est la
langue française est à l'honneur en ce
moment avec la semaine de la
francophonie pour l'occasion nous nous
sommes intéressés à une structure qui
permet aux femmes étrangères est
d'apprendre la langue de molière l'école
française des femmes a ouvert en janvier
une antenne à mantes la jolie
ce dispositif unique en france a fêté ce
lundi ses dix ans au château de
versailles découverte signé au rayon
ambiance studieuse dans cette salle de
classe un peu particulière nous sommes
au centre de vie sociale aimé césaire à
mantes la jolie
depuis le début de l'année une vingtaine
de femmes viennent plusieurs fois par
semaine perfectionner leur français au
sein de l'école française des femmes
fondée en 2008 par l'institut des
hauts-de-seine il s'agit du premier
établissement yvelinois vous proposons
du français langue étrangère ce n'est
pas de l'alphabétisation
donc ce sont des femmes qui sont allées
à l'école et qu'ils sont diplômés dans
leur pays d'origine
donc elles ont acquis les automatismes
de l'apprentissage à la différence de
l'alphabétisation ou là les femmes pour
la plupart ne sont pas allés à l'école
l'adhésion est de 15 euros pour une
année scolaire après un test de niveau
les femmes sont répartis en plusieurs
groupes pour un meilleur apprentissage
et doivent s'engager à suivre minimum
quatre heures de cours par semaine
en fin d'année si elles le souhaitent
elles peuvent passer un diplôme d'état
le delf diplôme d'étude de langue
française
zineb les oubliera ont toutes les deux
un projet professionnel et souhaitait
également mieux s'intégrer quelqu'un qui
arrive à qu'il n'arrive pas se
comprendre certaines choses barbares là
aussi on est comme une équipe
j'ai envie d'apprendre et écrire à mieux
parler sa tigresse tout simplement et
c'est très très bien
au lieu de rester qu'à la maison il faut
faut donner du temps pour soi
émancipation évolution sociale et
professionnelle
voici les valeurs portées par l'institut
des hauts-de-seine qui avait choisi le
château de versailles pour fêter ses dix
années d'existence
au total plus de 2000 femmes issues de
65 nationalités différentes ont pu
bénéficier de ce programme éducatif
unique en france
une idée qui a particulièrement séduit
le département des yvelines
l'idée c'est de pouvoir peut-être aussi
le développer sur d'autres quartiers
prioritaires
au delà de mantes-la-jolie sachant que
sur mantes la jolie c'est aussi un
ancrage sur le mantois
non c'est la première année des chéneaux
amat la jolie savait pas qu'il ya autant
de monde comme ça moi c'est la première
fois c'est pourquoi une visite
franchement je trouve ce merveilleux le
sait bien
fatma ainsi que les 400 femmes inscrits
dans les différentes structures ont pu
bénéficier d'une visite guidée du
château de versailles
l'année dernière son % des apprenantes
qui ont passé le diplôme d'étude de
langues françaises l'ont tenu produire
une électricité plus respectueuse dans
leur de l'environnement et le faire de
manière à citoyenne le credo des nerfs
city 78 vendredi au scarabée à la
verrière sera fondé la première
coopérative citoyenne et d'énergies
renouvelables des yvelines pour en
parler mike ness bonsoir bonsoir êtes
membres engagés de denner city 78 alors
il ya un an un autre membre de
l'association étaient venus en plateau
vous étiez à la recherche à l'époque de
toi pour y installer des panneaux
photovoltaïques y est aussi à la
recherche d'un modèle économique pour
cette coopérative qu'est ce qui a permis
de faire ce grand pas est d'arriver à
cette fondation qui qui sera fait du
coup vendredi
mais c'est vrai que depuis 2000 15 et la
création de la structure
on avait donc on a pas mal travaillé
mais le principal frein c'était le
modèle économique d'accord et c'est vrai
que là il ya un sérieux coup de boost
depuis la fin d'année 2010 8 et puis
cette année 2010 9 avec la région ile de
france qui a des objectifs de
développement des énergies renouvelables
et qui dans le cadre de son plan
d'action souhaite en fait soutenir des
projets citoyens d'énergies
renouvelables sur le territoire et qui
octroie donc des subventions subvention
est donc là ils ont lancé un appel à
projet en début d'année on a répondu à
cet appel à projets pour la partie
études on répondra ensuite pour la
partie investissement pour les panneaux
photovoltaïques en avril-mai et donc
l'idée c'est que là ils subventionnent
50% à 80% des études et ensuite 50% des
investissements impensé panneaux
solaires donc un grand pas grâce à ces
subventions ses potentiels subventions
la commune de la verrière aussi a été
intéressé par ce projet et une étude a
été réalisée sur plusieurs toits
communaux dont celui de l'espace soit
aimé césaire que l'on va peut-être voir
à l'image dans quelques instants
c'est hier que toutes les conditions
maintenant son sont réunis pour lancer
la coopérative oui c'est vrai que là ça
fait plaisir parce que ça fait quelques
années c'était un peu compliqué en plus
si les tarifs de rachat puisqu'au niveau
du modèle économique en produit
électricité que l'on revend ensuite à
edf tout ça c'est réglementaire avec un
tarif de rachat réglementaire c'est que
pour préciser la coopérative fonctionne
en fait comme une petite entreprise on y
adhère via départ l'idée c'est de
produire de l'électricité que vous
revendez ensuite par exemple la a aisni
10 et les sommes perçues finalement son
a eu des airs pardon les sommes perçues
sont redistribués aux membres ça permet
de gérer
du coup de l'exploitation des panneaux
photos le dic pendant une durée de 20
ans la durée de vie minimale des
panneaux solaires et c'est vrai qu'avec
les bénéfices chaque année qu'on
récupère il ya une partie de ses
bénéfices qui sont redistribués aux
investisseurs qu on espère un maximum
citoyens au niveau local les conclusions
sur l'étude qui a été réalisée à la
verrière a été positive du cou où elles
sont positives
ça fait quelques années contre avec la
direction technique de la ville de la
verrière
on a identifié maintenant bien identifié
trois toitures de bâtiments publics de
la commune avec l'a3 toiture qui ont la
même surface à peu près et donc la même
puissance en terme de production
électrique quand l'objectif c'est aussi
lié on imagine à la thématique actuelle
du respect de l'environnement de la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
c'est ceci est lié assassiné ce pays une
énergie finalement plus respectueuse de
l'environnement que vous voulez produire
oui tout à fait c'est vrai que en fait
la structure elle avait été créé suite
au festival alternatiba qui avait eu
lieu en 2015 à la verrière justement est
donc depuis depuis cette année là on a
des bons rapports avec
la municipalité et alternatiba qui
organise ces dernières années de plus en
plus justement les marches pour le
climat on s'inscrit complètement
dans dans le mouvement écologique
actuelle et c'est vrai que le slogan
d'un terrain tiba c'était changer le
système pas le climat donc évidemment ça
implique de changer nos modes de vie de
manière générale les infrastructures
notamment de deux déplacements les
transports publics comment se déplacent
même de manière individuelle
donc c'est vraiment un tout on
s'aperçoit quand même depuis quelques
années que fait on prend conscience je
pense dans la société française que les
lectrices démocratique social et
écologique sont liés et que tout est
intimement lié dans un monde où a priori
de plus en plus contraint en ressources
dans l'avenir est de plus en plus
instable notamment avec le changement
climatique
il est évident qu'on va devoir à
l'avenir partager davantage et de
personnaliser agir et agir ensemble et
l'angle citoyens de cette coopérative
donc fondation qui a lieu vendredi à
quoi va servir ce rendez vous qu'est ce
qui va être décidé vendredi
alors vendredi soir donc c'est un
l'événement vraiment de fondation de
cette structure qu'opera coopérative
citoyenne donc c'est dans la salle du
scarabée à la verrière l'arrière beau
spectacle
c'est en deux temps donc à 19 heures
dans un premier temps pendant environ
une heure vraiment discute avec les gens
qui seront présents dans la salle des
statuts par exemple du nom de la
structure du montant de la part ces 20
euros 50 euros 100 euros
l'idée évidemment c'est que il ya un
maximum d'investissement citoyens pour
financer les panneaux photovoltaïques et
leur installation juste pour un ordre
d'idées ça coûte combien de mains ce
projet à peu près alors là pour les 3,3
toiture pardon ses environs à 150000
euros
d'accord donc à prévoir un maximum de
financement citoyens au niveau local où
les gens qui sont intéressés
et puis après en complément il y aura un
prêt bancaire qui sera qui sera plus tôt
et éventuellement la subvention de la
région ile-de-france donc un projet qui
va coûter cher est-ce que les panneaux
fauteuil photovoltaîque ont-ils durée de
vie longue et ce qu'il faut les
remplacer
comment comment ça se passe alors il ya
certains équipements en fait pendant que
l'onduleur qui permet de transformer le
courant
le courant continu en courant alternatif
qu'il faut changer par exemple au bout
de dix ans mais mais les panneaux ont
une durée de vie minimale de vingt ans
ça peut aller au delà
mais donc le tarif de rachat en tout cas
est garanti lorsqu'on ont souscrit en
contractualise avec avec edf
ces minimums 20 ans pour le tarif de
rachat lui faire niveau rentabilité est
ce que ça s'est tout de suite c'est dans
le court terme ça sera plus dans le long
terme sur pour pour cette coopérative
alors en termes de rentabilité on ne
s'attend pas avant d'un taux de
rentabilité énorme c'est pas l'esprit du
projet l'idée c'est que si les gens ont
réussi à mettre un peu d'argent de côté
plutôt que de le
voilà le mettre à la banque et c'est
vrai qu'on sait pas trop en fonction des
banques ce qui est en effet en fait de
cet argent là la moins au niveau local
dans le cadre de la transition
énergétique pour lutter contre le
changement climatique un citoyen peuple
investir un peu de son argent et en
récupérer des bénéfices un petit peu
chaque année au fil au fil de l'eau
pendant les vingt ans et je précise
parce qu on arrive déjà fin de centre
cet entretien que la soirée se terminera
par la projection d'après d'un film de
cyril dion et de laure noualhat qui
revient sur les différentes initiatives
1 qui ont été abordés dans le film
demain également réalisé par cyril dion
merci mike ness d'après c'est sur ce
plateau
toutes les informations reproduites sur
le site des nerfs city soixante dix huit
pour ce rendez vous vendredi 22 mars à
partir de 19 heures à la salle du
scarabée à la verrière c'est une des
légendes vivantes du sport français
l'ancien cycliste raymond poulidor était
dans les yvelines ce week-end présent à
la 98e foire de chatou pour une
exposition sur sa carrière et une séance
de dédicaces nicolas landry sur des
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
poupou à chatou le célèbre coureur
cycliste français des années 60 70
raymond poulidor est venu dédicacer ses
livres à la fois international à la
brocante la possibilité pour lui de
rencontrer ses fans on retrace
évidemment un semblant parole l'ensemble
de ma carrière et la conversation rien
souvent avec jacques anquetil qui est
toujours présent ce fameux duel avec
jacques anquetil et toujours imposant
question comment se fait-il vous n'avez
pas gagné plusieurs tours de france
c'était ses meilleurs adversaires
jacques anquetil dans les années 60 et
eddy merckx dans les années 70 raymond
poulidor avait cette image d'éternel
second
mais cette exposition consacrée à sa
carrière mais aussi en lumière de
nombreuses victoires sur le plus
populaire c'est pas c'est pas d'éternels
seront pas s'il a gagné 157 cours sont
bas c'est une légende mais
c'est un peu le mythe d'un grand coureur
mais qui n'a pas réussi toujours faire
ce qu'il voulait c'est un personnage
un gars courageux qui a pas eu toujours
ma chance dans ces courses cyclistes
j'ai encore des la télé qui disait qu'il
était toujours 2e mais non parce qu'il a
quand même gagné pas mal de choses de
milan san remo tour d'espagne trophée
maillot vélo tous les trésors de
poulidor sont à retrouver durant cette
exposition prévue jusqu'au 24 mars à la
foire de chatou mais avant de laisser la
place à marylène iapichino pour
l'émission 7,8
lancé par les archives départementales
des yvelines elles sont à la recherche
de la presse perdu 200 mille pages de
journaux locaux anciens ont déjà été
numérisés mais de nombreuses éditions
restent introuvables
les yvelinoises sont invités donc à
l'occasion de la semaine de la presse à
compléter cette collection est deux
manières d'y contribuer faire un don
tout simplement de leur vieux
exemplaires de presse trouver chez eux
ou en bibliothèque ou bien intégrer une
équipe de bénévoles pour fouiller deux
poussiéreux cartons d'archivés un projet
collaboratif visant à sauvegarder le
patrimoine documentaire yvelinois c'est
la fin de cette édition le 7-8 journal
est à revoir sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 60,18 belle
soirée à tous
[Musique]